[Music]
there is almost nothing you eat that
won't have at some point travelled by
truck
but getting spanish melons like these to
supermarket shelves requires a lot of
petrol and the price of that hit record
highs
fuel costs alone have spiked 30 percent
for this importing business they in turn
left no choice but to charge more we
were low margin business high volume
turnover we don't have the margins to
absorb it we have to pass it on and
hopefully our customers
absorb some of it with us i've been
employed by the company for 40 years
and this is the biggest increase i have
ever personally seen and the downturn in
demand
has been the biggest downturn that i can
remember
and that downturn is seen too by those
selling straight to the public it is
food and fuel costs that largely drove
inflation to new 40-year highs they try
to offer affordable food here it's
getting harder chicken is increased by
30
phillips which is what we use a lot of
fillets or dumpling burgers we also do
like chicken strips that has gone up by
47
yeah oil as well as i'm sure you can
imagine oil has gone up 130
if customers don't come his staff could
lose work but they are feeling the
squeeze releasing a car
mortgages it's gonna we're gonna have to
start thinking about things completely
differently just to be able to manage
you go to the shop before we do 30
pounds we come back with half of the
trolley now with 30 pounds small basket
even my grandson he can carry the basket
because nothing inside there was a point
earlier this year when wages were rising
roughly in line with inflation there was
a degree to which people could manage
this but that's no longer the case pay
in real terms is now falling quite
significantly it is perhaps the key
issue underlining this week's strikes
other professions have threatened to
follow suit and what's being called a
summer of discontent is now a real
possibility is everyone successful with
something that opens and shorts
teachers are one group that have
threatened to strike public sector pay
is lagging much further behind many like
jill are fed up i think teachers do
deserve a big pay rise absolutely we've
been social workers we've been um
psychotic psychiatrists psychologists
we've picked things up when they've
fallen down we've helped parents we've
we've been everything to everybody
and i think that deserves some
recognition
and it may all grate further given the
government's now pledged pensions will
rise in line with inflation the
chancellor insists this won't make
things worse pensions are not an input
cost into the cost of producing goods
and services we all consume so they
don't add to inflation in the same way
there is increasingly a sense people
can't cope with much more
trucks of food will keep moving but so
will the cost helen and smith sky news